when Matthew Lillard who plays Aton
appeared on the weekly MTG podcast to
talk about magic the Gathering he also
revealed some interesting information
about his contract I just got cast in a
movie called Five Nights at Freddy's
it's a three picture deal with universal
and and Blum House unless Lillard is
also planning to appear in other
Universal and blumhouse projects as part
of that deal it can be assumed that he's
going to be part of a five nights
Trilogy this news lines up with director
Emma Tommy's desire to see the films be
the start of a franchise she'd like to
return to Tommy told Screen Rant that
there's so much more for potential
sequels to explore saying oh my gosh
well the lore is massive there was no
way we were ever going to fit everything
into one film nor was it the intention
so the answer is yes there's so much to
potentially bring into any sequels
should we be lucky enough to make them
so according to those directly involved
fans can have at least some expectation
of more Five Nights at Freddy's MMS that
delve deeper into the lore